voici là nous a dit bonjour bonjour
bonjour et bon retour de ce côté-ci de
la grande flaque d'eau qu'on retrouve on
sent qu on s'était parlé des pv quand
vous étiez de passage dans les studios
en juillet dans les studios de radio
canada international dont les dans la
galerie dans la pièce du fond
ah oui dans la pièce du fond menthe ici
de la galerie ni thématique sur la vie
de la roche à montréal vous aviez promis
d'avoir cet espace pourra présenter des
abbés ça y est c'est fait oui c'était
c'était encore un projet en juillet et
puis qui s'est réalisé puis s'est
réalisée pour moi c'était
un encouragement formidable parce que
venir si loin montré quelques oeuvres
l'artiste algérien je rêvais de le faire
mais je pensais pas réussir à le faire
et j'ai réussi
les ateliers sauvage en plein coeur
d'alger 500 m² avec un résident à tusket
présentation d'oeuvres et de création
d'oeuvres modernes
c'était difficile de faire un choix des
offres qu'on a misé oui oui c'était
difficile et il
c'était difficile de trouver des oeuvres
assez différentes les unes des autres
parce que je voulais montrer une palette
de ce qui se fait chez montrer des
artistes tous évidemment plutôt jeune
qui s'identifient comme contemporain
c'est à dire qui
[Musique]
des réponses et kyo qui sont impliqués
par les problèmes de l'algérie
d'aujourd'hui à centrer
très forte que ce soit ni au gorille ou
de soie à des rebelles dont six dans
leur biographie ce pas moi qui dis c'est
eux qui le disent c'est à dire qu'ils
sont en même temps intéressé par leur
statut d'artiste et ont longtemps
préoccupés par leur condition de deux
jeunes j'ai rien dans le temps une
période qui est assez incertain
qu'est ce qui fait que cette forme d'art
cette forme d'art niche et ces jeunes
plus vulnérables peu plus et la
surveillance
qu'est ce qui fait que ça vous touche à
ce point moi ça me touche d'abord ça ne
touche pas par la qualité parce que je
pense que
je suis toujours un peu comme devant un
miracle
les choses les choses de la vie
quotidienne matériels vont aussi mal en
égérie c'est-à-dire l'entretien des
routes
trop classe les ordures en commençant
par les chose la plus simple
l'entretien des immeubles il ya un
espèce de laisser-aller ya comme un vent
de la compétence répandue que quand on
voit la qualité du travail des artistes
on peut évidemment qu apparent vide 2-2
de se plonger dans cette ce territoire
qui est un territoire de l'excellent
c'est à dire qui est un territoire qui
qui peut être confronté à
l'international qui peut attirer tous
les regards à tous les regards c'est à
dire que deux d'un côté j'ai sans avoir
à en partir et s'il y parvenait à un
intéressant parce que
pourquoi ça peut intéresser évidemment
la qualité du travail mais il ya aussi
le fait que ce sont des artistes qui
sont intéressés par l'universel
vous voyez le sud vous avez vu le mur
y'a pas une référence lors il n'y a pas
une référence folklorique et je dois
dire que ce soit les plasticiens que ce
soit allé signer à ce que ce soit il ya
aujourd'hui j'appelle moi j'appelle ça
le cinéma monde comme j'appelle la
peinture mon jeu vous connaissez mon âge
donc j'ai participé aux premiers
mouvements artistiques
indépendant dans les années 60 c'était
des mouvements qui était très marquée
par l'algérie l'identité la guerre
disons le particularisme de de la
situation est sous par exemple tous les
films qui était fait il y avait de bons
films mais tous les films qui étaient
faits c'était pratiquement sur la guerre
d'algérie et d'une manière très frontal
et je dirais même une approche avant
pour ces primaires de l'identité or
aujourd'hui on est devant des films on
est devant les des installations devant
des oeuvres d'art qui s'adressent à
l'universel en partant d'un point
particulier c'est ça qui est intéressant
parce que j'ai beaucoup insisté en
communiquant sur mon projet et sur
l'événement qu'ils s'agissait ici de
montrer des artistes qui vivent en
algérie alger et annaba qui sont
confrontés tous les jours à la
quotidienneté de ce pays et qui nous
ramène ici pas une vision folkloriser ou
une vision une vision dix ans
ethniciser de l'algérie mais qui sont
vraiment confrontés à 7,7
ce fonds la question principale de
l'algérie d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire
c'est une question existentielle
profondément existentielle peut-être
plus que politique mais même si on peut
pas si on peut pas dégager deux films
c'est pour ça que les questions des
artistes aujourd'hui m'intéresse
beaucoup
parce qu'elles sont éminemment politique
mais qu'elles ne sont pas frontalement
politique et qu'elles sont éminemment
algérienne mais qu'elles ne sont pas
sympas unis folklorique mais universel
que ce qu'ils sont universels parce que
les questions qui se posent jours
risson des questions universelles et
l'accès à cet universel l'accès à ces
questions universelles c'est à dire que
quand vous posez une question
universelle sur l'homme
vous avez des réponses d'universel l'axé
même à cet universel que nous portons
nous est difficile et rempli d'obstacles
parce qu'évidemment je vous savez les
régimes politiques autoritaires ont
intérêt à favoriser des approches plus
folkloriser plus + neige plus
nationaliste entre guillemets le mauvais
côté du nationalisme c'est à dire de
favoriser cet orgueil forcené de
l'identité d'une identité et qui à force
de la force de se chercher dans cette
identité
on finit par se perdre en tant qu'homme
et en tant que femme et c'est ça qui m'a
intéressé c'est ça qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui chez les artistes
contemporains c'est qu'ils ont su faire
ce chemin vert
l'existentialisme de l'est
vers l'universel universel et c'est ça
qui m'a toujours intéressée et vous
portez un regard d'amour et de tendresse
sur ses oeuvres
en effet le tournoi il ya quelques
instants dans cet entretien
et cette façon que vous avez de parler
des gestes que vous vous trouvez ce sont
des grands gestes d'amour cet espace et
espace sauvage en plein coeur d'alger
c'est un geste d'amour de votre part
versé un seul formulaire
oui et je peux vous dire que je suis
récompensé parce que les retours que je
reçois sont absolument merveilleux
émouvant en ce moment il ya un artiste
qui qui aux ateliers et qui
un mot en me disant que parce que lui
s'étaient dirigés vers les installations
vers quelque chose de plus cérébral
de plus il nous dit que le fait d'être
dans l'atelier
ça lui a redonné envie de faire de la
peinture et du dessin c'est à dire de
revenir à une forme un peu plus original
de l'art plastique et je trouve ça très
intéressant
vous savez je crois qu'on en a parlé la
dernière fois mais j'insiste sur cela
parce que
évidemment les jeunes écoutent
de québec on voit l'algérie on voit des
pays des migrants ce sac le voit quand
on le voit de la france on voit un pays
des migrants est de plus en plus
malheureusement je n'ai pas fait des
gens qui parlent de gens qui parlent
aujourd'hui et les gens partent parce
que ce qu'il fait parce qu'il fait
partir les gens c'est plus tellement fou
des problèmes économiques parce que
l'économique l'algérie de bouiche sais
pas c'est pas mal
c'est le problème du désir le désir
cette notion qui est fondamental quand
on veut construire une vie quand on veut
faire un projet de vie le désir ça c'est
très important
et je m'adressais architecte âgé et
après avoir qu un speech comment j'ai vu
qu'elle était la philosophie de
l'aménagement des ateliers de la reynie
je pense que ce qui est et ce que j'ai
réussi à faire
c'est un objet de désir un objet de
désir c'est à dire des gens qui vont là
qui voit quelque chose qu'ils pensaient
être d'ailleurs c'est ramener alger 7
tailleur qu'on va toujours chercher et
ses mouvements montréal avec la quiétude
les détails sont trouvés le texte qui
accompagne cet entretien vous verrez
certains de ces moments de plaisir les
hôteliers sauvage
voici la tanzanie je vous remercie
beaucoup et de cet entretien est de nous
avoir amené ses oeuvres d'art merci et
je vous attends nombreux